tu auras un couvre-feu à 20h en vigueur
depuis le 15 décembre dernier
d'autres pays ont davantage tardé à agir
et ont rouvert prématurément leur bar où
leur restaurant et en conséquence ont dû
se résoudre à des mesures de confinement
beaucoup plus strictes allant même
jusqu'à la fermeture de l'os de leur
école comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui du
royaume-uni de l'irlande de l'allemagne
de l'italie ou du danemark
je pense sincèrement que notre stratégie
à la fois préventive et réactive
cette stratégie qui reste est cohérente
dans la durée a été la bonne par
ailleurs les premières données dont nous
disposons montrent que nous avons pu
passer les fêtes de fin d'année sans
flambées épidémiques grâce au
comportement responsable qui a été le
vôtre nous rappelant combien la lutte
contre cette épidémie est aussi la
sphère de tous et de chacun
les résultats de notre stratégie nous
place aujourd'hui dans une situation
comparative plus qu'honorable en europe
tant au niveau des taux d'incidence que
des taux de positivité des tests plus
précisément quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui est comment at elle évolué
depuis une semaine
notre situation reste évidemment
préoccupante même si elle s'est
globalement stabilisée au cours des
derniers jours
nous restons sur un plateau élevé avec
une moyenne hebdomadaire qui fluctuent
autour de 16000 contamination par jour
la pression sur nos hôpitaux restent
également à peu près stable mais se
situe elle aussi à un niveau élevé nous
avions hier 24700 sont neuf personnes
hospitalisées de l'aco vide en france
soit 28 personnes de plus que la semaine
dernière
parmi elles deux mille sept cent étaient
hospitalisés en réanimation soit 95 de
plus que jeudi dernier
notre situation je la qualifierais donc
par deux mots maîtrisé par rapport à ce
que l'on observe chez nous voisins mais
fragile car le virus circule encore
activement sur notre territoire est
d'autant plus fragile avec l'élément
nouveau que constitue l'émergence de
nouvelles souches plus contagieuse du
virus
nous surveillons évidemment de très près
ces nouveaux variants et je demande au
ministre des solidarités de la santé
olivier veyrat de vous faire partager en
toute transparence nos éléments de
connaissance qui se sont affinés depuis
la semaine dernière
ce ministre monsieur le premier ministre
la semaine dernière je vous parlais de
ces variants qu'on a identifié qui
peuvent circuler un peu partout dans le
monde notamment sur le territoire
national je rappelle brièvement ce que
c'est qu'un variant c'est lorsque des
mutations génétiques apparaissent dans
le patrimoine génétique d'un virus c'est
très classique ça arrive d'ailleurs ça
arrive assez souvent dans le coronavirus
la plupart des mutations n'entraîne
aucune conséquence certaines peuvent
potentiellement affaiblir le virus mais
certaines peuvent potentiellement le
renforcer et c'est ce qui nous inquiète
deux variants en particulier ont été
identifiés sur le territoire national le
premier vous le connaissez c'est le
variant d'origine identifie en tout cas
en angleterre qui s'appelle le voc 2020
ce variant qu'est ce qu'on sait de lui
d'abord qu'il est plus contagieux que le
virus qui circule classiquement en
france de l'ordre de 30 à 70% nous
disent les scientifiques notamment
anglais mais également les scientifiques
internationaux qui ont travaillé sur les
données et ce virus et potentiellement
aussi plus contagieux chez les enfants
en revanche ce virus ne donne pas
davantage de formes graves que le
variant qui circulent
traditionnellement en france et donc
c'est plus de cas mais pas des cas plus
graves
par ailleurs encore nous avons toutes
les raisons de penser que ce variance
voc 2020 est sensible au vaccin ce qui
est évidemment une bonne nouvelle en
angleterre l'apparition de ce variant a
provoqué une flambée épidémique
progressive qui a pris environ deux à
quatre mois dans une région du sud de
l'angleterre qui avait été peu touchés
au cours de la première vague et même du
début de la deuxième vague et ce variant
s'est répandu progressivement sur le
territoire jusqu'à devenir majoritaire y
compris d'ailleurs en à capitale
londonienne
le premier ministre l a dit l'angleterre
est actuellement avec un confinement
important plus de 1000 morts sont
enregistrés chaque jour dans ce pays et
nous devons donc tout faire pour
empêcher ce variant plus contagieux je
le répète de circuler en france
alors qu'est ce que nous faisons d'abord
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
est mobilisé pour aller traquer ce
variant partout où il peut être et le
professeur bruno lina m'a fait part des
résultats d'une étude qui était conduite
en lien avec l'ensemble des laboratoires
publics et privés et des centres de
recherche du pays
ses conclusions sur les suivantes pour
cent cas de coronavirus diagnostiqués en
france il y en a environ 1 entre 1 et 1
et demi qui correspondrait aux variants
c'est à dire que chaque jour il y aurait
entre 2 et 300 contaminations nouvelles
de corona virus variant voc 2020 sur le
territoire national je le disais tout à
l'heure
le virus est potentiellement ce variant
et pour tous potentiellement plus
contagieux chez les enfants nous avons
donc saisi d'une part le conseil
scientifique qui dans ses
recommandations ne propose pas la
fermeture des écoles mais demande une
surveillance renforcée
à l'instar des études menées par le
professeur lina et ses équipes et qui se
poursuivront les semaines à venir
d'autre part la société française de
pédiatrie avant-hier matin a publié un
avis dans lequel elle ne recommande pas
non plus la fermeture des écoles dont
elle considère qu' à ce stade elle
aurait plus de conséquences négatives
pour les enfants qu'elle offrirait de
garantie et elle nous enjoint à
augmenter les dépistages il en sera
question s'agissant des dépistages et
des propositions que nous faisons tout à
l'heure
par ailleurs nous mettons tout en oeuvre
pour empêcher la diffusion de ce virus
avec un contrôle renforcé aux frontières
nous exigeons aussi vous le savez des
tests avant le départ pour toutes les
personnes qui viennent d'angleterre pour
qu'elle puisse rentrer sur le territoire
national et nous renforçons tout ce qui
est contacts racing pourra les détecter
les chaînes de contamination et empêcher
que ce variant se diffuse avantage le
deuxième variante plus rapidement il est
originaire d'afrique du sud
ce variant il s'appelle le variant 501
de la même manière on sait qu'il est
vraisemblablement plus contagieux que le
virus qui circule traditionnellement en
france on a moins de données
scientifiques en revanche sur les
symptômes qu'il peut entraîner mais nous
n'avons pas à ce stade de raison de
penser qu'ils provoquent davantage de
formes graves mais ils restent plus
contagieux et nous devons là aussi le
freiner le ministre en charge des
outre-mer sébastien lecornu a fait un
certain nombre d'annoncés visant à
protéger notamment mayotte et la réunion
compte tenu de la proximité géographique
et nous mettons tout en oeuvre sur le
territoire national pour dépister ces
cas il y en a que quelques-uns à ce
stade qu'ils étaient des pistes et pour
vous donner un exemple une patiente
hospitalisée en réanimation dans un état
très grave dans un hôpital
d'ile-de-france a séjourné pendant une
dizaine de jours en mozambique au cours
du mois de décembre dans le cadre d'un
voyage une congrégation religieuse le
variant a été identifié chez elle le
contact racing a été activé plusieurs
cas positifs dans son entourage proche
et notamment dans sa famille ont été
identifiés toutes les personnes ont été
isolées et nous travaillons actuellement
pour faire le lien potentiel avec un
autre kloster de ce variant d'origine
sud-africaine ne variant 501 dans la
région de nantes avec une personne
également contaminée lors du voyage en
mozambique
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre à ce
stade donc la circulation de cette
souche ou de ces souches variante reste
limité dans notre pays mais vous l'avez
entendu son potentiel de développement
ne doit pas être sous-estimée
comme vous l'avez compris nous devons
donc tout faire pour éviter qu'elles ne
progressent rapidement et du fait de sa
plus grande contagiosité qu'elle ne
finisse par deux
hier la souche dominante comme le
royaume-uni malheureusement en fait
l'expérience cette situation nous
conduit donc à décider de mesures
complémentaires en premier lieu nous
allons durcir fortement les conditions
d'entrée sur le territoire national et
renforcer les contrôles les contrôles
aux frontières à compter de lundi
tous les voyageurs qui souhaitent venir
en france en provenance d'un pays
extérieurs à l'union européenne quels
qu'ils soient devront effectuer un test
avant de partir et il faudra présenter
un test négatif pour embarquer dans un
avion ou un bateau
de plus les personnes concernées devront
s'engager sur l'honneur à s'isoler
pendant sept jours
une fois arrivés en france puis à
refaire un deuxième test pcr à l'issue
pour les rares pays où il n'est pas
possible de réaliser un test sur place
au départ un laissez passer consulaires
pour être accordée par nos ambassades
pour motif impérieux
dans ce cas la personne se fera tester à
son arrivée en france et sera contrainte
de s'isoler sept jours dans un
établissement désigné par l'état pour
les déplacements en provenance d'un pays
de l'union européenne et notamment des
pays comme l'irlande ou le danemark
affrontés à une situation épidémique
difficiles les ministres travailleront à
l'élaboration d'un cadre de coordination
en vue du prochain conseil européen du
21 janvier
ce cadre devra évidemment prévoir des
exceptions concernant les frontaliers
les transporteurs routiers ou encore les
agents des compagnies de transport dans
ce cas dans le cadre de protocoles
sanitaires spécifiques
le ministre chargé de la santé vous l'a
dit nous prenons également des mesures
nouvelles pour nos territoires et
collectivités d'outre-mer la guyane et à
travers elle les antilles doivent être
le plus possible protégé du variant à
risque qui circulent en amazonie le
préfet prendra des mesures de
restriction adapté aux circonstances
locales
le contrôle des frontières sera renforcé
et des tests négatifs seront exigés pour
rejoindre les antilles et la montre que
la métropole comme c'est déjà exigé dans
l'autre sens des informations
préoccupantes indique que le variant à
risque d' afrique du sud serait déjà d'y
signer aux comores des mesures d'urgence
ont donc été prises dès le week-end
dernier pour tester en doublant à
l'arrivée des comores et pour
restreindre les déplacements à risque
ces mesures sont tout particulièrement
impérative pour protéger aussi la
réunion département peuplé de huit cent
mille habitants et géographiquement
isolés et de la même manière que pour la
guyane des tests négatifs seront exigés
pour les vols en provenance de mayotte
ou de la réunion vers la métropole
l'ensemble de ces mesures a pour
objectif de réduire drastiquement les
flux transfrontaliers afin de nous
protéger du risque de propagation des
souches variantes
j'ai demandé au ministre de l'intérieur
de prévoir un dispositif de contrôle
pour en garantir le respect sur
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
le couvre-feu s'appliquera à compter de
18 heures à partir de ce samedi et pour
au moins 15 jours
vous le savez cette disposition
s'applique d'ores et déjà dans 25
départements où nous avions observée ces
dernières semaines une progression plus
dynamique qu'ailleurs du nombre de
personnes malades de l'aco vide avec un
niveau d'incidence supérieur à 200 pour
cent mille
pourquoi ce choix il apparaît selon les
données disponibles à ce jour que cette
mesure a une efficacité sanitaires dans
les 15 premiers départements où le
couvre feu a été mis en oeuvre à 18
heures le 2 janvier dernier la hausse du
nombre de nouveaux cas y ait deux voire
trois fois plus faible que dans les
autres départements métropolitains comme
le montre la carte qui s'affiche avec
dans son dernier avis reçus hier soir et
qui sera rendue publique très rapidement
le conseil scientifique a du reste
confirmé l'utilité du couvre-feu dans la
lutte contre la pandémie
nous appliquerons donc cette mesure dans
tout le pays car la situation a évolué
ces derniers jours alors que la reprise
épidémique était concentré fin décembre
sur certains départements la circulation
virale concerne désormais tout le
territoire ainsi plus aucun département
ne présente un taux d'incidence a 7
jours inférieur à l'objectif de 50 pour
cent mille habitants
si l'incidence reste plus élevée dans
l'est du pays là où le couvre-feu
anticipé s'applique déjà c'est désormais
dans l'ouest de la france que la
dynamique est la plus forte
cette mesure de couvre feu obéit à une
logique de freinage préventive elle
permet de graduer notre riposte et
d'essayer d'éviter de passer à des
mesures plus difficile
comme nous l'avons déjà connu à deux
reprises l'année dernière elle vise à
réduire encore davantage les contacts
sociaux sur les heures de fin de journée
tout en permettant le maintien des
activités économiques éducatives et des
déplacements pendant la journée
cela signifie qu'à partir de samedi 18
heures chacun devra être chez soi
les dérogations très limitées seront les
mêmes que celles actuellement
applicables pour le couvre-feu à 20
heures elles permettent notamment de
revenir du travail ou d'aller chercher
ses enfants à l'école ou à la crèche
mais il ne sera pas possible de sortir
pour des motifs personnels de même sauf
les exceptions liées aux missions de
service public
tous les lieux commerces ou services
recevant du public seront fermés à 18h
dans la mesure où 7 me dans la mesure où
cette disposition va réduire les
horaires d'ouverture des commerces et
afin d'éviter les concentrations des
clients aux heures ouvrables
j'invite tous les établissements qui le
souhaitent à se saisir des possibilités
d'ouverture supplémentaire sur la pause
déjeuner dans la plupart des
départements des dérogations permettant
l'ouverture des commerces le dimanche
ont pu être accordé suite aux
concertations locales menées par les
préfets et j'invite là aussi les
commerçants pour s'en saisir pour étaler
les frais et nous verrons s'il ya lieu
de prolonger ses dispositions en février
j'ai également demandé au ministre de
l'intérieur et au préfet devait y est
rigoureusement notamment dans les
grandes surfaces commerciales au strict
respect des jauges destinées à limiter
les flux georges prévu dans les
protocoles sanitaires que nous avons
arrêté avec ces professionnels avec ce
renforcement du couvre feu
nous restons cohérents avec notre
stratégie de réaction graduées et
proportionnées aux risques épidémiques
en effet à l'heure où je vous parle la
situation sanitaire n'exige pas que nous
mettions en place un nouveau confinement
qui constituerait une décision très
lourde dont nous connaissons le coût
humain économique et social je vous
rappelle que lorsque nous avons décidé
le second confinement fin octobre nous
observions de l'ordre de 50 mille
contamination par jour contre eux seize
ou dix sept mille aujourd'hui c'est bien
moins également que les niveaux observés
aujourd'hui dans les pays autour de nous
où l'épidémie flanc la situation
hospitalière étaient également beaucoup
plus tendu mais je veux être
parfaitement clair avec vous si nous
constatons dans les prochains jours une
dégradation épidémique forte nous
serions conduit à décider sans délais
d'un nouveau confinement
car nous devons comme nous n'avons cessé
de le faire depuis le début de cette
crise nous préparer à toute éventualité
avec le président de la république nous
avons souhaité maintenir ouverts les
établissements scolaires et c'est pour
nous je les dis un objectif fondamental
le confinement du printemps dernier à
creuser les inégalités scolaires
et accru les risques de décrochage de
nombreux enfants plusieurs de nos
voisins européens ont fait récemment je
vous le disais tout à l'heure un choix
différent du nôtre
en fermant les écoles ou en repoussant
la rentrée scolaire
c'est le cas de l'allemagne du
royaume-uni du danemark de l'irlande ou
encore de l'item nous souhaitons tout
faire pour l'éviter
la condition pour pouvoir tenir cette
ligne et que nous renforcions nos
dispositifs sur trois points d'abord le
protocole sanitaire dans les cantines
scolaires sera renforcée nous allons
suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre les
activités physiques et sportives
scolaires et extrascolaires en intérieur
et puis nous allons augmenter encore
notre capacité de dépistage dans les
établissements scolaires avec un
objectif de 300 mille tests par semaine
soit plus d'un million par mois
ces mesures qui vont vous être détaillé
par le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer doivent permettre
de réduire davantage encore les risques
et d'intervenir plus rapidement encore
en cas de circulation du virus au sein
d'un établissement scolaire
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs
comme vous le savez depuis le début de
la crise au mois de mars dernier
nous avons deux critères le premier
c'est assurer la continuité des
apprentissages une continuité la plus
normale possible et en second lieu
protéger au maximum la santé la santé
des élèves la santé des personnels la
santé des français avec l'année que nous
venons de connaître
et comme vient de le rappeler le premier
ministre nous sommes plus que jamais
convaincus qu'il est de première
importance de maintenir ouvertes les
écoles ce n'est pas complètement une
exception française il ya d'autres pays
européens qui maintiennent les écoles
ouvertes mais nous sommes fiers pour
l'année 2020 d'avoir permis que la
france soit un des pays et même le pays
qui a maintenu le plus de jours d'école
pour ses enfants
c'est évidemment essentiel et comme l'a
rappelé encore récemment le conseil
scientifique
c'est évidemment essentiel quand on
mesure les avantages et les
inconvénients d'aller à l'école de ne
pas aller à l'école de maintenir les
écoles ouvertes car il ya des
conséquences éducatives sociales
psychologiques sanitaire même pour les
enfants de ne pas aller à l'école
nous pouvons donc être collectivement
fier d'atteindre cet objectif nous le
sommes pour les raisons que le premier
ministre vient de dire et nous pouvons
l'être tout simplement parce que les
objectifs sont clairs et je veux
remercier de nouveau les professeurs les
personnels de l'éducation nationale des
collectivités locales qui ont ils nous
ont permis jusqu'à aujourd'hui
d'atteindre cet objectif
cet objectif que nous avons réussi en
2020 réussissons le en 2021
pour cela nous devons faire avancer le
curseur du protocole sanitaire dans un
sens un peu plus strictes dans le sens
que vient d'indiquer le premier ministre
et même si on me le scolaire à ce stade
la circulation du virus reste
relativement maîtrisé nous devons nous
adapter sur certains points afin de
maintenir la protection la plus étendue
possible pour l'ensemble des personnels
et des élèves
cela signifie d'abord le maintien du
fonctionnement en mode hybride
c'est-à-dire en parties en présence en
partie en distance pour les lycées au
delà du 20 janvier
vous savez que vous avez indiqué que
cette mesure pouvait être éventuellement
terminer pour le 20 janvier en réalité
nous la prolongeons
puisque depuis le début du mois de
novembre les deux tiers des lycées sont
rentrés dans ce mode de fonctionnement
et que cela fonctionne au cas par cas en
tenue en tenant compte des réalités
physiques de chaque lycée les lycées qui
le souhaitent pourront donc continuer à
être en mode hybride
et encore une fois nous regardons cela
sur chaque cas particulier dans le
contexte épidémiologique actuelle nous
considérons que ce mode hybride est
efficace mais nous avons une vigilance
particulière pour les élèves de
terminale qui passent le baccalauréat
cette année et donc notre recommandation
est que les élèves de terminale sur le
plus possible en présence dans
l'établissement
s'agissant des collèges à titre
exceptionnel lorsque des établissements
connaissent des contraintes qui sont
dues aux bâtiments et bien il peut y
avoir aussi le mode hybride qui est
choisie cela est autorisé au cas par cas
pour les rectorats en général pour la
classe de 4ème et la classe de troisième
mais ça doit rester exceptionnel puisque
nous savons bien qu'à cet âge là les
élèves s'ils ne sont pas à l'école
peuvent avoir des activités qui sont
éventuellement même plus contaminantes
des mesures aussi son seront prises pour
les cantines scolaires
là aussi nous savons que c'est
éventuellement un maillon faible de
l'organisation puisque c'est le moment
où on enlève son masque le moment aussi
où comme on le sait l'activité
consistant à manger collectivement peut
présenter des risques en termes de
contamination à l'école primaire il n'y
aura pas de brassage possibles lors des
repas entre les classes les élèves d'une
même classe quand je roule tous les
jours ensemble à la même table et si
cela n'était pas possible dans certaines
écoles les temps de prise de repas
seront allongés pour permettre
l'établissement
l'étalement pardon des classes en
cantine en dernier recours on peut avoir
la solution de repas remporté proposés
aux enfants
là aussi c'est au cas par cas que cela
doit se décider dans l'enseignement
secondaire
l'hybridation des lycées lorsqu'elle est
choisie permet de lever normalement la
pression sur le temps des repas
puisqu'il ya moins d'élèves présents
dans l'établissement
et si certains collèges reste en tension
pour organiser le temps de restauration
dans le strict respect des normes
nouvelles dont le détail est
d'abandonner ce soir et aux acteurs de
l'éducation nationale et aux
collectivités locales
et bien dans ce cas les temps de service
serait rallongé ou des repas à emporter
serait proposé en troisième lieu les
cours d'éducation physique et sportive
comme vient de le dire le premier
ministre sont eux aussi modifier toutes
les pratiques que l'on qui sont les
pratiques d'intérieur sont suspendus je
dis bien suspendu ça signifie que nous
souhaitons évidemment être en capacité
de les ré ouvrir dès que ce sera
possible
c'est vrai en milieu scolaire c'est vrai
en milieu extra scolaires nous avons été
très actifs pour que les pratiques
sportives puissent reprendre ces
dernières semaines pour les mineures
mais malheureusement nous devons
suspendre pour quelques semaines
probablement ce type d'activité mais
entendu je reste très actif avec roxana
maracineanu avec les milieux sportifs
pour que dans le futur nous puissions ré
ouvrir dès que cela sera possible
enfin en quatrième lieu et là aussi le
premier ministre a commencé à le dire
notre stratégie de test prend un nouveau
tour avec dès le mois de janvier dans
les écoles les collèges et les lycées
une possibilité massive de déploiement
pour plus d'un million de personnels et
des élèves pour accentuer notre
surveillance de la circulation du virus
en milieu scolaire et en complément de
ce que nous faisons déjà c'est-à-dire le
traçage des cas contacts ce qu'on
appelle parfois le contact racing va
évidemment continuer donc nous le
mettons en place avec chaque agence
régionale de santé depuis la rentrée
comme vous le montre le graphique que
vous voyez à l'écran et maintenant nous
aurons non seulement ce traçage donc qui
continuera mais aussi la possibilité
pour certains établissements d'avoir la
venue d'une équipe de dépistage de tous
les personnels tous les élèves sur place
chaque fois qu'il y aura trois cas de
contamination et puis il y aura aussi
l'identification de tous les personnels
lycéens et collégiens qui se verront
donc proposer un test dans les 48 heures
dans ce type d' hypothèse nous
continuerons aussi à fermer des classes
des écoles des collèges et des lycées au
cas par cas en lien avec les autorités
de santé locales
chaque fois que un certain nombre de cas
nous conduisent à cette décision
voici monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les mesures qui sont
donc prises en matière scolaire
elles doivent nous permettre de
continuer à accueillir les élèves dans
un cadre protecteur et c'est évidemment
une vigilance de tous y compris des
familles dans la façon dont nous
préparons nos enfants à avoir le respect
des gestes barrières au quotidien et à
respecter l'ensemble des nouvelles
règles je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre nous
sommes donc toujours dans cette logique
préventive et cette même logique nous a
conduits dans le cadre du confinement à
suspendre les enseignements en
présentiel dans l'enseignement supérieur
ce passage à 100% d enseignement à
distance a été très difficile à vivre
pour nombre d'étudiants qui ressentent
pour beaucoup d'entre eux un profond
sentiment d'isolement mais aussi pour
certains de vraies difficultés
psychologiques et ce en dépit des
efforts de leurs enseignants que je
remercie pour assurer la continuité
pédagogique à distance c'est pour le
gouvernement une source de préoccupation
majeure
nous avons déjà arrêté avec la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et dans le
cadre de concertation conduite à la fin
de l'année dernière un certain nombre de
dispositions pour créer de l'emploi pour
les étudiants pour assurer des tutorats
pour aider à leur prise en charge
psychologique lorsque c'est nécessaire
l'effectivité de ces mesures n'est pas
encore complète
et il n'est pas certain qu'elle soit
suffisante nous avons autorisé depuis la
rentrée de janvier que des étudiants en
grande difficulté puissent revenir par
petits groupes de dix
quelques heures par semaine nous
autoriserons à partir de la semaine du
25 janvier la reprise par demi groupe
des travaux dirigés des élèves de
première année puis si la situation
sanitaire le permet si la situation
sanitaire le permet aux étudiants des
autres niveaux
cette reprise très progressive attendue
par les étudiants mais aussi par leurs
professeurs dont je veux saluer ce soir
l'engagement comme je salue celui de
l'ensemble des personnels de l'éducation
je recevrai demain avec la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur la conférence
des présidents d'université des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
ainsi que les organisations syndicales
étudiantes pour préciser les conditions
et les modalités des évolutions d'un
retour progressif en présentiel je
demande à madame frédéric vidal ministre
chargé de l'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche de venir vous présenter le
détail de ces dispositions qu'encore une
fois nous concerterons demain matin
merci monsieur le premier ministre
chacun le sait il a été demandé aux
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
d'assurer la continuité pédagogique dans
l'immense majorité à distance et seul un
nombre très restreint
renseignements ont pu se tenir en
présentiel et dans des conditions
sanitaires strictes depuis le début du
second confinement cette situation nous
le savons tous est extrêmement difficile
pour les étudiants qui sont privés de
relation humaine directe avec leurs
enseignants mais aussi avec leur père
les étudiants ont le sentiment que la
crise sanitaire a volé leurs plus beaux
moments
je sais aussi l'inquiétude de leurs
familles mais aussi celle de leurs
enseignants et de l'ensemble des
personnels qui chaque jour sont
confrontés à leurs difficultés qu'elles
soient économiques sociales ou
personnels enseignants enseignants
chercheurs personnels des crous et des
établissements recteur tous nous sommes
mobilisés afin d'accompagner au mieux
ses 2,7 millions d'étudiants qui sont
l'avenir de notre pays je sais aussi
l'action complémentaire de nombreuses
collectivités territoriales pour
soutenir les jeunes dans cette période
et je tiens aussi à les en remercier ici
de nombreux dispositifs ont été mis en
place pour soutenir financièrement les
étudiants depuis le premier jour de la
crise sanitaire
nous poursuivrons ces efforts mais nous
savons qu'ils ne sont pas suffisants les
1600 référents dans les cités
universitaires sont à l'oeuvre pour
soutenir les plus fragiles pour
maintenir du lien social et de
l'accompagnement humain les 20000
tuteurs étudiants seront là pour
soutenir pédagogiquement les étudiants
le nombre de psychologues dans les
universités sera doublée ce semestre et
de nouveaux personnels sociaux
permettront d'accélérer l'accès aux
aides d'urgence délivrée par le réseau
des oeuvres pour tous les étudiants
nous avons pleinement conscience du
découragement qui va croissant chez
certains étudiants et particulièrement
chez ceux qui vivent
seul c'est pourquoi nous n'avions pas
fait le choix de la fermeture complète
des établissements lors du second
confinement le maintien des travaux
pratiques ou des formations ne pouvant
pas être délivrée à distance est resté
autorisé une deuxième étape a été mise
en place depuis le 4 janvier dernier
avec l'arrivée progressive dans chaque
établissement des étudiants par groupes
de dix les étudiants les plus fragiles
il s'agit aujourd'hui conformément à ce
que le président de la république avait
annoncé le 4 décembre dernier à ce qui a
été décidé lors du dernier conseil de
défense de franchir une nouvelle étape
afin que le second semestre puisse se
dérouler dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
en attendant que la campagne de
vaccination nous permettent de retrouver
une vie normale sur les campus
universitaires dans les écoles et les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
nous devons permettre aux étudiants de
renouer le contact en présentiel avec
leurs enseignants il est impératif que
nous puissions progressivement tracer
ensemble ce chemin qui nous permettra de
passer d'une majorité d'enseignement à
distance y ait là une majorité
d'enseignement en présentiel
conformément à ce que vient d'annoncer
le premier ministre et dans le respect
du calendrier universitaire dès la
semaine du 25 janvier les travaux
dirigés pourront donc reprendre en
demi-groupe pour les étudiants de
première année c'est une étape sur ce
chemin avant de pouvoir y intégrer
davantage d'étudiants dès demain avec
les conférence des présidents
d'université et des directeurs
d'établissements ainsi qu'avec les
organisations étudiantes
nous allons construire les conditions
permettant cette reprise échelonnée des
enseignements dans le supérieur
les protocoles d'accueil devront
prévenir le brassage des étudiants
garantir les règles de distanciation
ils devront éviter que les étudiants
restent sur site pour les pauses
méridiennes
en lien avec les équipes du ministère
des solidarités la santé dépistage
individuel ou collectif seront déployés
des tests antigénique seront mis à la
disposition des services de santé
universitaire dont je salue l'action au
quotidien et tout ceci sera fait en
partenariat étroit avec les rectorats et
les autorités de santé pour nous
permettre de surveiller l'évolution de
l'épidémie dans les établissements je me
réjouis vraiment que les liens humains
si important pour l'acquisition des
connaissances comme pour la construction
personnelle et psychologique des
étudiants puissent renouer au cours des
prochains jours et des prochaines
semaines
je crois qu'il en va de l'avenir de
notre jeunesse
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la ministre mesdames et messieurs les
les mesures que je viens de vous
annoncer mesure jamais parfaitement
conscience difficile et qui résultent de
du maintien au niveau de cette pandémie
nous conduisant à l'it est plus que
jamais à consacrer toutes nos forces à
la campagne vaccinale cette campagne
vaccinale qui a démarré en ce début
d'année et qui nous offre enfin un motif
tangible d'espoir une vraie perspective
de sortie de crise la première
vaccination a eu lieu dans notre pays le
27 décembre lors de la première semaine
de janvier
cent mille personnes ont été vaccinées
au cours de cette deuxième qui n'est pas
terminé nous pensons que 250 mille
autres le seront nous avons vacciné hier
57 mille personnes en une seule journée
cette montée en puissance va se
poursuivre encore la semaine prochaine
notamment dans les ehpad et en ouvrant
dès lundi prochain la vaccination à
toutes les personnes âgées de plus de 75
ans à la fin du mois de janvier nous
serons au dessus du million de personnes
vaccinées qui était notre objectif
initial
ce résultat ne s'explique pas parce que
nous aurions reçu plus de vaccins mais
parce que nous avons est passé d'une
semaine les chances de la deuxième
injection et que nous observons beaucoup
moins de pertes dans l'utilisation des
doses reçues
j'entends encore des commentateurs
s'étonner de ce que nous ne vaccinerons
pas tout de suite tout le monde quel que
soit l'âge ou la situation de santé je
veux une nouvelle fois rappeler ici un
élément fondamental
ces nouveaux vaccins ont une double
efficacité ils limitent la transmission
et surtout surtout ils préviennent la
personne atteinte de développer une
forme grave de la maladie
or nous savons que l'immense majorité de
celles et ceux qui meurent ou qui sont
hospitalisés pour coville cent des
personnes âgées ou atteintes d'une
pathologie chronique
ce sont donc eux qu'il faut protéger les
premiers c'est une question éthique
c'est aussi une question d'efficacité
car plus nous les vaccineront vite plus
vite nos hôpitaux seront mis à l'abri
des risques de surcharge et plus vite
nous pourrons lever les mesures de
restrictions qui pèsent sur toute la
population conformément à notre
stratégie de priorisation des plus
fragiles et un accord avec les autorités
scientifiques et les associations de
patients
j'ai décidé d'ouvrir dès lundi 18
janvier également la vaccination aux
personnes quel que soit leur âge
présentant une des pathologies
conduisant à un très haut risque de
formes graves de la maladie
plus de 700 centres de vaccination
seront ouverts lundi grâce à la
mobilisation conjointe de l'état des
élus locaux et des professionnels de
santé
je tiens à remercier l'ensemble des
personnes qui contribuent à l'hôpital et
en ville ce que j'ai personnellement
constaté avec le ministre olivier
ferrand samedi à tarbes ou encore ceux
ce matin à metz je salue je salue les
équipes de l'hôpital de metz c'est un
petit clin d'oeil pour leur formidable
mobilisation et ce mouvement at est à la
fois de cette forte mobilisation et de
la mise en place de dispositifs
efficaces
à compter de demain matin 8 heures il
sera possible de prendre rendez vous par
internet ou par téléphone auprès de ces
centres je veux insister sur le fait que
la vaccination de ces premiers publics
prioritaires va nécessairement prendre
plusieurs semaines
tout le monde ne pourra pas trouver un
rendez-vous immédiatement il faudra être
patient et comprendre que si nous
ouvrons de nombreux centres tout de
suite
nous dépendons des livraisons de vaccins
qui elle même dépend du rythme de
production des laboratoires tous les
pays du monde sont logés à la même
enseigne tous les pays européens ont
passé ensemble des commandes massives au
prorata de leur population
la production des vaccins déjà autorisé
montent en charge d'autres vaccins
pourraient être également autorisé par
les autorités scientifiques européennes
dans les prochaines semaines je demande
au ministre des solidarités et de la
santé de vous faire un point plus
détaillées sur le déroulement de notre
stratégie vaccinale et sur ses
perspectives
olivier veyrat vous êtes de plus en plus
favorable dans toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion à la vaccination et vous avez
raison puisque le vaccin est un moyen de
vous protéger et demain j'espère de
pouvoir protéger vos proches et pour
tous de retrouver une vie tel que nous
l'avions avant que la pandémie ne
démarre il y a un an vous l'avez dit
monsieur le premier ministre deux cent
quarante sept mille personnes étaient
vaccinées hier soir donc nous avons vous
le savez simplifiée amplifiés et
accélérés 190 mille professionnels de
santé ont déjà été vaccinées hier nous
atteindrons je n'ai pas encore les
chiffres du jour mais nous ne serons pas
loin des 300 milles selon toute
vraisemblance et à partir de la semaine
prochaine la campagne de vaccination
dans les ehpad les établissements pour
personnes âgées va prendre
de l'ampleur et en l'espace de trois
semaines nous comptons vacciner
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes parmi les plus vulnérables du
pays et je me joins aux remerciements
qui ont été formulées par le premier
ministre pour toutes celles et ceux qui
s'activent partout sur le territoire
national dans les plusieurs centaines de
centres qui sont déjà opérationnels donc
à partir de lundi nous ouvrons la
vaccination céderait aux personnes âgées
de 75 ans et plus et sur avis de la
haute autorité de santé mais également
du professeur alain fischer pourront
également être vaccinés à partir de
lundi quelques 800 mille personnes qui
sont atteintes de maladie
particulièrement grave et qui les
rendent très vulnérables au risque de
formes graves de lakovic 19 parmi ces
maladies il y à l'insuffisance rénale
chronique sévère un cancer sous
traitement les transplanter d'organes
mais également les personnes atteintes
de trisomie
pour toutes ces personnes il leur faudra
consulter leur médecin leur médecin
traitant qui leur fera une ordonnance
qui leur permettra de rejoindre donc les
personnes qui sont appelées à se faire
vacciner c'est à dire les personnes de
75 ans et plus au total ce sont 6 4
millions de français qui sont appelées à
se faire vacciner à partir de lundi
alors comment prendre rendez vous trois
moyens un moyen que je vous recommande
chaleureusement c'est de contacter le
centre de vaccination le plus proche de
chez vous vous pouvez trouver son
adresse son numéro de téléphone moyen de
le contacter auprès de votre mairie de
votre médecin de votre pharmacien
près de vos amis ou même dans la presse
locale vous avez deux autres moyens pour
prendre rendez vous le premier c'est le
site internet www.sante.dz qui vous
permet de prendre rendez vous
directement en ligne pour un créneau de
vaccination dans le centre le plus
proche de chez vous si vous n'êtes pas
en mesure de le faire par vous même vous
pouvez évidemment vous faire aider par
un proche et enfin vous avez la
possibilité d'appeler un numéro de
téléphone national c'est le 0 800 00 910
0 800 00 910 un numéro de téléphone qui
sera activé à partir de demain matin
huit heures il sera ensuite ouvert 7
jours sur 7 de 6 heures du matin à 22
heures pour la métropole et les
territoires ultramarins bien sûr et ce
numéro de téléphone vous orientera
directement vers les plateformes
téléphoniques du centre de vaccination
le plus proche de chez vous quelques
informations importantes
d'abord les vaccinations se feront
progressivement au rythme de nos
livraisons comme c'est le cas en france
en europe mais également partout dans le
monde
à la fin du mois de février nous aurons
les doses pour vacciner 2.5 millions de
français et si certains vaccins dont
nous espérons la validation dans les
prochaines semaines venait d'être
effectivement validé eh bien nous
pourrions disposer au total de 4
millions de doses de vaccins
voyez donc il y a 6 4 millions de
personnes de plus qui sont appelées à se
faire vacciner et que d'ici la fin du
mois de février nous n'aurons pas encore
toutes les doses pour vacciner tout le
monde mais je vous le dis si ça prend du
temps plusieurs semaines soyez rassurés
en définitive vous seraient vaccinés si
en dépit de tous les efforts qui ont été
faits par toutes les équipes techniques
je salue notamment cédric au secrétaire
d'état en charge du numérique qui fait
beaucoup le site si le site internet
aussi les lignes téléphoniques devaient
être surchargé ce ne serait évidemment
que temporaire vous donner un ordre
d'idée alors même que nous ne pouvions
pas encore prendre rendez vous sur le
site sante.fr nous enregistrions près de
huit mille connexions toutes les
secondes sur le site internet ce matin
le site est renforcée aujourd'hui il
était mis à jour et demain matin et ce
soir et demain matin il sera pleinement
opérationnel je me réjouis que vous
soyez nombreux à vouloir vous faire
vacciner et je vous le redis toutes les
personnes qui souhaitent être vaccinés
le seront mais cela prendra plusieurs
semaines chaque centre de vaccination
sur le territoire national il y en a je
le dis plusieurs centaines chaque centre
c'est précisément de combien de doses de
vaccins ils disposent et combien de
combien de doses de vaccin il disposera
pour les quatre semaines à venir
chaque centre est donc en capacité de
donner des rendez vous pour les quatre
semaines à venir et nous avons insisté
de manière assez strictes pour que ces
centres évidemment de prêts va pas
prévoit pas plus de créneaux de rendez
vous qui ne dispose de doses afin
d'éviter de convoquer des personnes de
façon inutile donc tout est mis en place
pour commencer cette vaccination grand
public à partir de lundi à nouveau un
grand merci à tous les soignants des
hôpitaux publics notamment mais
également privé des libéraux des élus et
des personnels administratifs des ars
des préfectures qui sont des milliers à
travailler toutes les semaines tous les
jours pour pouvoir organiser cette
campagne de vaccination dans les
meilleures conditions
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez compris mesdames et messieurs
l'accès à la vaccination nous permet
d'espérer une sortie progressive de
cette crise d'ici l'été prochain
d'ici là le virus évidemment et continue
à produire ses ravages et ses dégâts et
nous conduisent donc à prendre comme
aujourd'hui encore des mesures destinées
à son freinage et à la freinage de sa
propagation
cela fait bientôt une année que nous y
sommes contraints et je sais
parfaitement tout ce que cela peut
représenter pour toutes celles et ceux
qui en subissent les effets dans leur
vie quotidienne et plus encore dans leur
activité professionnelle
mais vous le savez aussi la france a
fait ce qu'il fallait pour venir en aide
à tous ceux là aux acteurs culturels aux
entreprises aux salariés et aux
indépendants au commerce aux hôtels
cafés restaurants professionnels de la
montagne association au monde sportif
professionnel de l'événementiel et à
tous ceux qui ont subi et qui subsistent
encore l'impact de cette crise
nos mesures de soutien ont été mises en
place rapidement au printemps dernier
nous les avons renforcé et adapté au fur
et à mesure de la crise
au cours des derniers mois avec un
dialogue constant avec tous les secteurs
concernés
ces dispositifs fonctionnent et ont
permis de sauver des millions
d'entreprises et d'emplois
je sais combien tout le monde voudrait
plus de visibilité sur la suite
quand est-ce que nous pourrons rouvrir
ce qui aujourd'hui ne l'est pas quand
est-ce que l'activité économique pourra
reprendre durablement
toutes ces questions sont évidents
légitime difficile compte tenu des
incertitudes de répondre à ces questions
de manière précise même si
l'identification de perspectives et
d'échéance constitue une priorité en
lien avec les représentants des secteurs
concernés ce sur quoi je m'engage avec
certitude c'est que nous maintiendrons
le dispositif de soutien aussi longtemps
que cela sera nécessaire
le présent la république l'a encore
répété nous devons entendre le besoin de
sécurité de stabilité que nous expriment
les acteurs économiques et sociaux
nous ne vont pas ajouter de
l'incertitude économique à l'incertitude
sanitaires nous devons rester à leur
écoute et savoir ajuster encore lorsque
c'est juste et nécessaire
tous nos dispositifs d aide c'est le
sens des présentations qui vont vous
être maintenant faites par les ministres
qui au quotidien au quotidien sont à
l'écouté de leurs secteurs
professionnels pour adapter le
dispositif dead est apte accompagnement
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la relance
elisabeth bornes en charge du travail et
de l'emploi et roselyne bachelot
ministre de la culture je les invite
chacun à leur tour à venir présenter la
situation à ce jour des différents
secteurs d'activité dont ils ont la
charge et surtout les conditions de
prorogation et d'adaptation des
dispositifs d'accompagnement qui ont été
mis en place monsieur mise économie
merci monsieur le premier ministre a
comme vous venez de l'indiquer monsieur
le premier ministre
plus les mesures de sécurité sanitaire
dur que nous sommes obligés de les
renforcer
plus elles sont difficiles à supporter
pour les entrepreneurs pour les artisans
pour les commerçants pour les
indépendants qui ne souhaiteraient
qu'une seule chose travailler et
travailler le plus rapidement possible
dans des conditions normales avec le
premier ministre avec le président de la
république nous avons une conscience
aiguë de la lassitude de la colère du
désespoir parfois de toutes ces
professions
nous ne pouvons pas donner de visibilité
sur un calendrier de sortie de crise
sanitaire
mais nous voulons donner de la
visibilité sur notre soutien économique
ce soutien économique il a été immédiat
depuis le premier jour de la crise il a
été massif
il a été comparable tout ce qui se fait
dans les autres pays européens
et comme vient de l'indiquer jean castex
il durera aussi longtemps que cela sera
nécessaire et nous l'adapterons à la
réalité de la situation de chacun
puisque nous sommes en discussion
quotidiennement avec l'ensemble des
professions qui sont touchés par ces
mesures de restrictions sanitaires
le pilier de ce soutien économique
restera le fonds de solidarité
ce fonds de solidarité je veux dire tout
de suite qu'un nouveau formulaire pour
les aides de décembre sera disponible
demain vendredi 15 janvier tous ceux qui
ont accès ce fonds de solidarité
pourront s'inscrire ce nouveau
formulaire et toucher les aides au début
de la semaine prochaine je sais combien
est important d'avoir un calendrier
précis de versement des aides
économiques pour les acteurs qui sont
concernés à la demande du président de
la république et du premier ministre
nous introduirons trois changements
majeurs sur ce fonds de solidarité et
nous ferons un effort particulier le
premier changement concerne le produit
de la vente à emporter et de livraison à
domicile
nous avons décidé pour tous ses produits
de la vente emporté des livraisons à
domicile qui concerne en particulier les
restaurateurs qu'il ne sera pas intégrée
dans le chiffre d'affaires de référence
pour le calcul du montant de l'aide du
fonds de solidarité ce sera uniquement
pour les restaurateurs il n'y aura
aucune déduction
cette facilité la vaudra à partir du
mois de décembre de l'année dernière
donc à partir du mois de décembre 2020
cela restera la règle pour les mois à
venir par conséquent tout ce qui sera
touchée par les restaurateurs en matière
de produits de vente à emporter et de
livraison à domicile je salue les
efforts d'imagination qui ont été faits
par les restaurateurs dans ce domaine là
ce sera pour eux non déductible du front
solidarité applicable à compter du mois
de décembre de l'année passée
le deuxième changement c'est que les
fournisseurs de ce secteur des cafés de
la restauration
ceux qui sont en première ligne mais qui
ne sont pas fermées je pense au commerce
de gros de poisson je pense aux hôtels
je pense aux brasseurs au blanchisseurs
au torréfacteur ont droit aujourd'hui à
une aide qui est plafonné à 10000 euros
ça n'est pas suffisant nous avons donc
décidé que dès lors qu'il perdait 70 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires
ils auraient droit à cette fois ci à une
aide en pourcentage leurs chiffres
d'affaires ils pourront choisir cette
modalité là jusqu'à 20% de leur chiffre
d'affaires
dans la limite de 200 millions il passe
donc d'une aide forfaitaire à 10000
euros à une possibilité d'avoir accès à
une aide en pourcentage de leur chiffre
d'affaires
jusqu'à un montant pouvant aller jusqu'à
deux cent mille euros
cela sera applicable pour le mois de
décembre là aussi pour couvrir le mois
de décembre passé qui était
particulièrement difficile pour ses
fournisseurs et il n'y aura pas de
limite de nombre de salariés alors qu
auparavant il y avait une limite en
nombre de salariés à 50 salariés tous
les entrepreneurs
fournisseurs seront donc concernés il
suffit d'avoir perdu 70% de son chiffre
d'affaires il n'y a plus de plafond en
nombre de salariés et l'aide pourra
aller jusqu'à deux cent mille euros par
mois le troisième changement concerne
les coûts fixes
parce que nous avons parfaitement
conscience que pour beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs le poids des coûts fixes
des charges fixes je pense en
particulier aux loyers est absolument
insupportable
dans cette période de fermeture de
limitation de leurs activités ça
concerne bien entendu des structures
importantes je pense aux chaînes
d'hôtels je pense aux restaurateurs qui
ont plusieurs restos rendre dans une
même ville je pense aux activités indoor
je pense au bowling je pense aux salles
de sport toutes ces activités là ont
besoin que leurs charges fixes soient
couvertes
nous prendrons donc en charge les coûts
fixes de toutes les entreprises de ces
secteurs
dès lors qu'elles réalisent plus de 1
million de chiffre d'affaires par mois
et nous allons travailler que les
parlementaires aux meilleures façons de
baisser ce seuil de 1 million d'euros
qui je sais peut être pénalisant pour un
certain nombre de petites structures
très spécifiques
cette aide exceptionnelle pour les
charges fixes s'ajoutera à l'aide du
fonds de solidarité
elle sera plafonnée dans un premier
temps à une aide de trois millions
d'euros c'est la négociation que nous
avons conduite avec la commission
européenne pour la période de janvier à
juin 2021
mais c'est un point de départ c'est 3
millions d'euros et nous allons
continuer à négocier avec la commission
européenne pour voir si nous ne pourrons
pas relever encore ce plafond de 3
millions d'euros de prise en charge des
charges fixes pour les entreprises de
taille plus importante qui ont des
charges fixes très lourde et qui n'ont
en face pas de revenus ou que des
revenus très limité c'est 2,3 cm
changements que nous avons voulu
introduire avec le président de la
république et le premier ministre
enfin nous allons faire un effort
particulier un effort particulier pour
nos amis viticulteurs les viticulteurs
sont injustement touchées par les
sanctions américaines au titre du
conflit airbus bruit nous allons
évidemment faire le maximum avec le
ministre en charge du
coppens extérieur franck riester pour
essayer de trouver une solution avec nos
amis américains ce conflit airbus boeing
mais cela prendra plusieurs semaines
et en attendant les vins tranquilles et
cognac ont des tarifs de 25 %
supplémentaires qui pénalise
terriblement les exportations de vins de
spiritueux vers les états unis qui sont
le premier marché de destination de ses
vins et spiritueux ils pourront donc ces
viticulteurs bénéficier d'une aide
jusqu'à deux cent mille euros par mois
dès lors qu'ils perdent 50 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires
ils pourront également bénéficier de la
prise en charge des coûts fixes avec le
plafond de 3 millions d'euros pour les
grosses structures dont je viens de
parler
j'espère que cela aidera les
viticulteurs à passer ces moments
difficiles et je veux leur redire que
nous poursuivons tous notre travail pour
obtenir aussi le soutien de la
commission européenne avec un fonds de
compensation est évidemment le règlement
définitif du conflit commercial avec les
états unis le deuxième volet dette que
nous voulons apporter concernent les
prêts pour passer cette période
particulièrement difficile des centaines
de milliers d'entreprises près de 650
milles ont contracté des prêts garantis
par l'état et je sais que certains vont
approcher avec beaucoup d'inquiétude
la première échéance de remboursement de
leur capital si l'on souscrit un prêt en
mars 2020 et ce 10 mars 2021 il faut
commencer à rembourser ou en mai 2020 en
mai 2021 il faudra commencer à
rembourser la première échéance
nous allons donc permettre à toutes les
entreprises qui le souhaitent de
différer d'une année supplémentaire
le remboursement de leurs prêts garantis
par l'état si elle souhaite le
rembourser au 1er mars 2022 au lieu du
1er mars 2021
elles pourront le faire ce différé de
remboursement d'un an supplémentaire du
prêt garanti par l'état est de droit
pour toutes les entreprises quelle que
soit leur secteur d'activité
et quelle que soit leur taille et je
tiens vraiment à remercier la fédération
bancaire française avec laquelle nous
travaillons en parfaite intelligence
depuis le début
de cette crise pour le sens des
responsabilités dont elle a fait preuve
et pour cette solidarité qui est la
seule manière pour nous tous de sortir
de cette crise économique
j'invite évidemment toutes les
entreprises à contacter dès maintenant
leur banquier leur agence bancaire pour
définir les modalités d'amortissement de
leurs prêts en tenant compte de ce
différé d'amortissement supplémentaire
qui leur est accordé je sais également
qu'au delà des prêts garantis par l'état
d'autres prêts ont été contractés qui ne
sont pas dans le champ des prêts
garantis par l'état et qui sont aussi un
motif d'inquiétude pour beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs à ma demande
les banques se sont donc engagés à
examiner favorablement toute demande de
moratoire ou de report d'échéances pour
les entreprises qui sont les plus
touchés par la crise
sur une base personnalisés j'avais donc
là aussi toutes les entreprises qui sont
en grande difficulté qui souhaiteraient
pouvoir bénéficier de ce moratoire ou ce
report d'échéance sur un prêt qui n'est
pas un prêt garanti par l'état à faire
la démarche auprès de leur agence
bancaire
troisième élément de soutien les
cotisations sociales
je veux simplement confirmer que nous
maintiendrons en janvier les
exonérations de cotisations sociales et
les aide au paiement des cotisations
sociales qui ont été mises en place en
décembre
l'objectif est simple zéro charges
sociales pour les entreprises qui sont
fermées ou qui sont lourdement pénalisés
dans les secteurs liés à l'hôtellerie le
café la restauration le sport le monde
la culture ou le monde événementiel
quand je recevrai très prochainement car
je sais qu'ils ont une inquiétude toute
particulière étant donné l'absence de
perspectives de ventes e enfin le
dernier point céder différé
d'amortissement
c'est un point qui peut paraître
technique mais qui est très important
pour les hôtels pour les restaurateurs
il sera possible de différer
l'amortissement comptable des biens qui
ont été sous utilisés en 2020 afin de
soulager des comptes des entreprises et
de préserver leurs fonds propres pour
les hôtels pour les remontées mécaniques
pour les discothèques pour les salles de
sport pour les résidences de tourisme
pour les restaurants
ce différé d'amortissement doit être
un vrai soulagement pour leur trésorerie
l'ensemble de ces mesures que nous avons
prises avec le président de la
république et le premier ministre
représente un coût de 4 milliards
d'euros environ par mois
c'est dire l'importance du soutien
économique que nous avons apportées
depuis le début de cette crise et que
nous continuerons à porter jusqu'à ce
que la crise sanitaire soit derrière
enfin je voudrais terminer en signalant
que au delà de ce soutien économique
nous voulons aussi avec jean castex
préparer l'avenir économique et je
voudrais insister sur les trois enjeux
stratégiques qui devront nous permettre
de construire l'avenir
le premier c'est évidemment permettre
aux français de consommer dans
l'économie française et d'investir dans
l'économie française
les 100 milliards d'euros qu'ils ont
épargné pendant cette crise cela suppose
la confiance la lisibilité dans notre
stratégie économique et financière est
bien entendu une garantie que nous
n'avons cessé de donner avec le présent
la république et le premier ministre
nous n'augmenterons pas les impôts des
français et nous continuerons à engager
les baisses d'impôts que nous avons
engagé depuis plusieurs années sur
l'impôt ces sociétés pour les
entreprises les impôts production sur
l'impôt sur le revenu ou sur les taxes
d'habitation c'est un choix stratégique
dont dépend la confiance économique des
ménages et leur capacité à consommer ces
100 milliards d'euros le deuxième enjeu
stratégique comme nous l'a demandé le
président de la république hier c'est
d'engager sans délai la relance 100
milliards d'euros supplémentaires qui
devront être décaissés dans les
meilleurs délais nous y veillons avec le
premier ministre
de manière quotidienne afin de nous
assurer que la relance économique
démarre dans les territoires enfin le
dernier enjeu stratégique
au delà de la consommation de la relance
économique
c'est les fonds propres des entreprises
ces fonds propres des entreprises sont
absolument décisif pour qu'elle
investisse kelly nobes qu'elles créent
de la richesse et qu'elle crée de
l'emploi
ces fonds propres opposeront largement
soit mise à disposition de prêts
participatifs pour un montant d'environ
20 milliards d'euros et nous a juste
auront la garantie de l'état au volume
de ses prêts participatifs
je préciserai le 28 janvier prochain les
modalités de ces prêts participatifs
soutenu par l'état
dès que nous aurons fini la négociation
avec la commission européenne sur ce
sujet je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur nice et lisa
bête bornes
merci monsieur premier ministre 1 depuis
le début de la crise le gouvernement
soutient les entreprises et protège les
emplois en prenant en charge la
rémunération des salariés avec
l'activité partielle en novembre ce sont
près de 3 millions de salariés qui
étaient en activité partielle après
avoir été près de 9 millions lors du 1er
confinement
cet outil puissant a permis de préserver
des centaines de milliers d'emplois en
période de fermeture ou de baisse
d'activité avec les nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires
nous avons décidé de poursuivre ce
soutien massif selon les modalités
suivantes pour les entreprises qui sont
totalement fermés comme par exemple les
restaurants les salles de sport ou
encore les discothèques ou qui sont
fermés partiellement comme les commerces
désormais soumis au couvre feu à 18
heures l'état continuera de prendre en
charge 100 % de la rémunération versée
aux salariés
et cela tant que les mesures de
restrictions administratives s'applique
pour les entreprises des secteurs
protégés comme par exemple les hôtels ou
les professionnels de l'événementiel
l'état continuera de prendre en charge
100 % de la rémunération versée aux
salariés jusqu'à fin février à compter
de mars
cette prise en charge à 100 % sera
maintenue pour ceux qui enregistrent une
baisse de 80 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires
pour les autres le reste à charge pour
l'employeur sera de 15 %
enfin pour tous les autres secteurs
l'état continue des listes de les
soutenir jusqu'à fin février avec un
reste à charge inchangé de 15% pour les
entreprises à compter de mars
ce reste à charge passera à 40 %
si les conditions sanitaires sont
réunies j'invite par ailleurs les
entreprises et les branches
professionnelles qui anticipent des
baisses d'activité plus durable à
s'emparer du dispositif d'activité
partielle
longue durée et à conclure des accords
avec les représentants des salariés
ce dispositif est plus protecteur pour
les salariés et les entreprises que
l'activité partielle de droit commun il
protège l'entreprise le temps que la
situation économique s'améliore à ce
jour plus de 6000 entreprises
représentant huit mille établissements
se sont emparés de ce dispositif
ce sont plus de 420 mille salariés qui
sont ainsi protégés la sauvegarde de
l'emploi est notre priorité et reste
notre priorité jour merci merci beaucoup
madame la ministre
et enfin si j'ose dire roselyne bachelot
monsieur le premier ministre
chers collègues mesdames et messieurs
vous l'avez entendu la situation
sanitaire est extrêmement dégradée et
l'apparition de variant du virus suscite
beaucoup d'inquiétude
c'est en raison de ce contexte épidémie
grave que nous devons sans joie nous
résoudre pour le moment à vivre avec des
lieux culturels fermée au public
musées monuments cinéma salle de
spectacle et avec un couvre feu fixé
maintenant 18 heures cette fermeture des
lieux culturels n'est pas propre à la
france
quasiment tous les pays autour de nous
soumis à la même pression épidémiques
ont pris la même décision
en allemagne les théâtres les cinémas
sont fermés depuis le 2 novembre dernier
les musées depuis le 15 décembre tous
les établissements culturels sont
fermées en autriche en grèce en hongrie
aux pays-bas en pologne en lituanie en
suisse et la liste n'est pas exhaustive
s'il reste quelques territoires où les
théâtres et cinémas restent ouverts ils
se comptent sur les doigts d'une main et
l'évolution de la situation épidémique
les menaces son art par exemple la
nouvelle d'un confinement en portugal
qui jusque là avait échappé à ceux
décisions comme nous l'avons fait depuis
le début de la crise avec constance nous
continuerons à soutenir et à accompagner
les acteurs culturels
jusqu'à ce que les conditions
économiques de fonctionnement soit
restaurée le gouvernement n'a pas failli
et ne faillira pas sur ce front merci
monsieur le premier ministre et monsieur
le ministre de l'économie du maintien
des mesures transversales telles que
vous les avez présenté fonds de
solidarité améliorer exonération des
cotisations sociales prêts garantis par
l'état et par la ministre du travail et
de l'emploi lisabeth bornes activité
partielle dans nos entreprises
culturelles ont largement profité et qui
donc continuer en bénéficier nous
prolongerons également ça c'est très
important pour ce secteur
les dispositifs spécifiques qui ont été
mis en place pour la culture pour chaque
secteur qu'il s'agisse des aides aux
entreprises ou aux personnes fonds de
sauvegarde fonds d'urgence dispositif
d'indemnisation tout cela sera maintenu
avec une attention particulière sur la
préservation de l'emploi artistique et
culturel et sur les artistes auteurs par
ailleurs nous poursuivons notre travail
d'échangé de concertation avec
l'ensemble des professionnels de la
culture
c'est en jeu je le partage avec olivier
ferrand pour que nous ne soyons plus
confrontés à chaque inflexion de la
situation sanitaire à un choix binaire
laisser l'établissement ouvert ou fermé
c'est pourquoi avec les professionnels
nous sommes en train de définir un
modèle adaptable qui nous permettent
lorsque nous seront sortis de la phase
aiguë de la crise de pouvoir rouvrir et
progressivement de revenir à un
fonctionnement normal
la tente des professionnels est forte
seuls des publics l'est tout autant
enfin je voudrais rappeler que les
répétitions les tournages les captations
sans public ainsi que l'accueil
d'artistes en résidence reste toujours
possible pour les professionnels pour
l'instant la situation sanitaire est
trop dégradée est trop instable pour
envisager une date ferme de réouverture
mais je sais aussi avec pablo neruda que
le printemps est inexorable
merci beaucoup mesdames et messieurs mes
chers concitoyens face à ce drame que
vit notre pays et le monde depuis des
mois et qui pèse sur tant et tant
d'entre nous la priorité des priorités
pour sortir de cette crise elle recours
à la vaccination et nous mettrons toutes
nos forces dans la réussite de ce
programme exceptionnel dans l'ordre et
dans la clarté programme inédit de
vaccination mais nous devons
collectivement faire preuve de patience
et de responsabilité car ce n'est pas
avant plusieurs mois que la vaccination
pourra nous protéger de manière
suffisante
d'ici là nous devons elle a simplement
continué à nous protéger contre le virus
par tous les moyens à notre disposition
l'application stricte des gestes
barrières le port du masque le lavage
des mains le recours au dépistage
au moindre doute et le respect des
consignes d'isolement l'amélioration de
nos prise en charge médicale et le
soutien à nos soignants dont je salue
encore et toujours
l'engagement et la mobilisation de tous
les instants une course de fond est
engagé et je suis persuadé qu'ensemble
nous la gagnons je me tiens à votre
disposition avec les ministres pour
répondre à vos questions
bonsoir frédérique prabonnaud france
télévisions monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez parlé du double intérêt du
vaccin et de sa capacité à limiter la
transmission
je voulais savoir sur quelles données
vous vous fondez pour affirmer ça et
j'avais une deuxième question
je pense pas entendu parler de
télétravail
je voulais savoir ce qu'il en est et
quelles étaient les recommandations
concernant télétravail merci allez une
autre question ne prend que deux par
deux et maintenant monsieur morel le
premier ministre je voulais notamment
vous avez avec la ministre de la
recherche et des universités parler de
l'ouverture et du desserrement dans les
universités en revanche est ce que l'on
peut considérer également que les
concours et examens vont également se
dérouler normalement
est ce que demain vous avez annoncé une
réunion avec les présidents
d'universités est-ce que vous c'est une
réunion de concertation ou est-ce que
vous allez annoncer un plan d'ouverture
des universités concernant la
vaccination
les professionnels de santé demande à
pouvoir vacciner le plus possible
notamment des retraités est ce que cette
vaccination seront ouvertes à l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé qui sont en
capacité de vacciner sur la recherche je
voulais dire vous poser une question
madame vidal
également il y à une nouvelle agence
anrs maladie épidémique ou maladies
émergentes ont dit qu'elle n'a pas de
financements pérennes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous annoncer
notamment cas l'on n'aura et que ça ne
se fera pas au détriment vous savez que
c'est très important
d'autres pathologies en particulier
évidemment du sida vih
merci alors on va commencer par le
ministre à santé évidemment parce que
des questions sur la vaccination ensuite
la ministre viendra j'en profite tant
qu'ils ont gêne pour vous parler de d'un
mot des universités puisque vous nous
avez interrogé sur les perspectives de
la réunion de demain mais c'est d'abord
une réunion de concertation qui a pour
objectif de voir comment les décisions
que nous avions prises avec eux en fin
d'année 2020 se déploie manière
effective de les tester sur les annonces
que j'ai fait ce soir pendant lequel
mesure le monde enseignement supérieur
va s'emparer les mettre en place est
évidemment d'identifier
éventuellement des dispositifs
complémentaires il ne s'agit pas d'un
plan de couverture à court terme des
universités soyons clairs tout la
situation sanitaire nous incite à la
plus grande prudence
l'objectif c'est à la fois de donner des
perspectives et à court terme de
vraiment voir comment on peut ramener en
présentiel ceux des étudiants qui n ont
absolument besoin pour des raisons
pédagogiques et extra pédagogique la
ministre revient à monsieur le ministre
3.11 12.11 et demi pour répondre à la
question vous avez posée pourquoi est ce
qu'on dit que le vaccin pourrait freiner
la contamination
c'est l'une des questions vous avez posé
le vaccin de pfizer et le vaccin moderna
parce que les premières observations
dans certains pays dans lesquels il ya
eu un certain nombre de personnes déjà
vaccinées
tant que tu as montré ses les
scientifiques de ces pays aussi qu'ils
le disent qu' il y aurait moins de
transmission du virus est par ailleurs
des données publiées par dans le cas du
vaccin moderna mais dont le mécanisme
est le même que celui de pfizer tente à
montrer qu'effectivement il y aurait une
réduction des contaminations jeu mais
encore évidemment des guillemets vous me
connaissez on met des guillemets tant
que tout n'est pas écrit dans le marbre
de la science mais on a des bonnes
raisons d'espérer et j'ai envie de vous
dire que ça fait du bien
quant au fait de savoir que le variant
et est sensible aux vaccins ce sont les
scientifiques qui nous le disent sur une
base assez simple qui est que le vaccin
cible entre guillemets sensibilise à une
protéine qui n'est pas concernée par le
variant voc 2020 ni par le variant 500
et c'est heureux encore une fois je mets
des guillemets mais là aussi on a quand
même quelques bonnes raisons d'espérer
il en profite pour vous dire que j'ai eu
des chiffres de vaccination du jour
soixante dix mille personnes de plus ont
été protégés aujourd'hui ce qui porte à
3 118 mille le nombre de personnes
vaccinées vous voyez qu'on continue
d'augmenter
pour celles et ceux qui s'inquiétaient
du rythme le rythme est bon et
s'amplifiera encore dans les jours et
semaines à venir
enfin pour la question de pascal morel
sur les professionnels de santé qui
peuvent vacciner j répondu la semaine
dernière
mais je vous le confirme tous les
professionnels de santé même d'ailleurs
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
étudiant et pour un certain nombre
d'entre retraités peuvent être amenés à
vacciner dans les centres de vaccination
ça se passe aujourd'hui dans des centres
lorsque nous aurons d'autres vaccins qui
ne se conserve pas à moins 70 mais plus
sobrement dans un frigo entre 2 et 8
degrés eh bien nous pourrons exploiter
tout le maillage français en pharmacie
en cabinets médicaux pour développer
encore plus et aller encore plus vite
dans des conditions de sécurité
évidemment
madame la ministre recherche
d'enseignement supérieur sur la question
des examens et des concours que vous
avez abordé en fait ils sont pour
certains en train de se tenir
la possibilité est donnée aux
établissements de les organiser à
distance vous avez organisé en
présentiel
il ya des disciplines des matières qui
se prête à une évaluation à distance
d'autres qui ne s'y prête pas et donc
c'est les établissements qui organise
cela pour ce qui concerne les examens
nationaux et les concours nationaux
là on est sur les mêmes protocoles à la
sortie du premier confinement c'est à
dire des protocoles sanitaires strictes
et des examens et les concours qui se
déroule en présentiel avec une
organisation qui est pris en charge avec
les établissements et notamment avec
l'inspection générale que je veux
remercier une fois de plus pour pour
cette organisation
effectivement l'agent sa mairesse
reacting a été créée elle a été dotée en
plus des financements de l'agencé rms
pour un fonds de départ purement
d'organisation administrative et elle
sera bénéficiaire d'un programme de
recherche spécifique maladies émergentes
d'un montant d'environ 50 millions
d'euros que nous sommes en train de
construire avec elle
donc voilà ne vous inquiétez pas il y
aura bien un budget qui ne viendra pas
empiéter sur le budget de la mairesse
dans la mairesse
disposais précédemment voilà merci
madame la ministre à vannes j'ai pas
évoquer le télétravail parce qu'en
réalité les règles par rapport à celle
que nous avions décidé en fin d'année
n'ont pas changé donc la ministre va
voulais préciser ou rappelé merci plus
près ministre alors en effet des règles
ne changent pas en matière de
télétravail donc vous savez que depuis
fin octobre
nous avons souhaité utiliser au maximum
le télétravail pour réduire les
interactions notamment sur les trajets
domicile travail et en marge du travail
ce qui veut dire qu'un salarié dont la
totalité des tâches peuvent être faites
à distance doit être 100% en télétravail
mais suite aux retours que nous avons eu
des salariés des drh des partenaires
sociaux sur les difficultés qu'ils
éprouvent un certain nombre de salariés
qui sont en télétravail qui était en
télétravail cinq jours sur cinq depuis
le début novembre
nous avons décidé de faire évoluer le
protocole national le protocole
sanitaire en entreprise à partir du 7
janvier ce qui a été fait donc en
permettant aux salariés qui étaient en
télétravail à 100% qui en expriment le
besoin de revenir une journée par
semaine au maximum dans l'entreprise
donc c'est cette règle là qui est
maintenu à laurent poursuivre sur les
questions bonjour bastille auger pour
tf1 lci sur la campagne de vaccination
qui commence à partir de lundi pour
toutes les personnes qui ne peuvent pas
se rendre à un centre de vaccination
parce qu'elles sont chez elles et
qu'elles peuvent pas se déplacer
concrètement qu'est ce qui va être fait
pour elle vous parlais la semaine
dernière monsieur le ministre je crois
de solutions de plus par exemple est ce
que toutes les personnes de plus de 75
ans qui veulent se faire vacciner auront
accès à ce type de solution et puis par
ailleurs vous parliez des publics
fragiles
comment une personne concernée sera si
elle est concernée ou pas par cette
première campagne de vaccination par
exemple est ce que toutes les personnes
diabétiques de tous les âges pourront se
faire vacciner à partir de lundi
prochain
et puis une précision sur les
restrictions il ya bientôt les vacances
de février qui arrivait ce que vous
envisagez de limiter les déplacements de
département en département
pour éviter une circulation du virus est
ce que vous recommander aux français ou
est-ce que vous conseiller aux français
de réserver leurs vacances ou est-ce que
là vous leur demander d'attendre merci
les notes question et je réponds de l'
afp des élus du grand est où le
couvre-feu prévaut où le couvre-feu de
18h prévoit depuis quelques jours vous
ont alerté ce matin sur certains effets
néfastes comme l'engagement des grandes
surfaces le samedi matin la saturation
des routes des transports entre 17h et
18h et puis aussi les conséquences
psychologiques pour les gens dont le
quotidien se réduit peu ou prou au
travail
comment comptez faire pour prévenir ou
tout du moins atténuer ses effets là une
question sur la vaccination vous l'avez
dit près de six millions et demi de
personnes sont appelées à se faire
vacciner
à quelle échéance vous espérez les avoir
vacciné et peut-on déduire que
mécaniquement quand ces personnes là
parmi les plus prioritaires seront
vaccinés
des levés de restriction progressive
auront lieu et puis une toute petite
précision sur les travailleurs
frontaliers et ans dans quelle mesure
les restrictions de déplacement que vous
avez annoncé auront des effets sur ces
travailleurs là notamment avec la suisse
qui est curieux merci alors on prend
moins de questions mais si et chacun
d'entre vous impose davantage de son ca
compte pas c'est bon alors que le dmi
jacente et veuille bien se se préparer
je réponds en ce qui me concerne au
moins deux questions
d'abord vous effectivement j'étais dans
le grand est avec vous monsieur ce matin
où j'ai interrogé enfin tout cas sur un
département même s'il y avait le présent
de région les élus ça servait à ça aussi
un l'objectif de mon déplacement n'était
pas simplement de deux visites et
l'organisation de la vaccination là bas
mais aussi dans un département dans une
agglomération qui a recours au couvre
feu depuis 18h quels étaient les leurs
impressions leurs sentiments
vous avez en toute transparence entendu
avec moi pour peu qu'ils avaient des
avis partagés certains expliquant que la
mesure était à leurs yeux plutôt
efficaces d'autres et en va des moins
enthousiastes
effectivement ils vont ils ont bien
soulever les questions que nous
connaissions du reste que vous avez
rappelé je les dis vous étiez témoin là
encore j'ai rappelé au préfet du lieu
que notamment s'agissant des personnes
qui se concentrent dans certains grands
centres commerciaux le week-end ou pas
d'ailleurs
enfin le week-end en particulier puisque
cela pourrait être l'un des effets du
l'avancé de l'horaire du couvre-feu
jeudi je rappelle bruno le maire le sait
parfaitement puisque c'est lui qui les a
négocié avec eux qu'il existe des
protocoles très stricts que il faut à
tout prix faire respecter dans une
grande surface on a calculé desgeorges
il faut mettre quelques à l'entrée qui
compte il y en a qui le font très bien
et quand la georges et la densité sont
atteintes on entre plus sauf si
évidemment ça sort de notre côté donc il
faut que chacun s'astreignent à
respecter cela pour éviter des
phénomènes qui effectivement se
produisent mais qui ne sont pas normaux
donc cet échange avec avec les élus
d'autres qu'elle n'ait pas assisté avec
aussi des personnels de santé sur leur
ressenti par rapport à l'effet du
couvre-feu anticipé adducteurs ont
contribué à nous éclairer
ainsi qu'il vient dans toutes les
discussions des concertations qui avait
été conduite sous l'égide du mise à
santés et qui globalement mais vous
l'avez vu nous sommes plutôt conforté
dans le sentiment qu'il était utile de
généraliser cette mesure
s'agissant autre question mais olivier
aurait pu répondre mais comme on l'a vu
là bas aussi
effectivement il ya la question des
personnes de plus de 75 ans à partir de
10 ou hulu d'âge moindre curé des
difficultés à se rendre dans les centres
vaccination ça peut arriver même si
elles sont aussi souvent une famille qui
peut les aider à se déplacer là c'est un
banquier clairement identifiés nous
avons dit que les acteurs locaux
ils connaissent parfaitement la
situation trouve des situations adapté
qui peuvent être je crois que c'était
évoqué par votre question des transports
on a aussi entendu parler je ne sais pas
si on l'a dit ce matin c'est sûr qu'on
en a parlé à tard de samedi afin que les
acteurs locaux nous en parler à table
des équipes mobiles qui pourraient aller
se déplacer au domicile des personnes
concernées je vous le dis je je je fais
absolument toute confiance sous la
coordination du préfère à l'ensemble des
acteurs des territoires pour apporter
les solutions les plus adaptées possible
à chaque situation
il est trop tôt de la question m'a été
posée de dire si on va limiter les
déplacements pour les vacances de
février en particulier je le comment
dire je ne recommande pas ce soir
d'annuler les réservations pour répondre
très précisément à votre question nous
adapterons faut que les circonstances
mais faut donner à une question précise
une réponse claire et s'agissant des
travailleurs frontaliers je crois que
j'ai j'ai donné la réponse est donc que
nous à avoir des discussions avec la
suisse puisque comme vous l'avez dit
elle est hors union européenne
et s'agissant des travailleurs
frontaliers il y en a là où nous étions
ce matin mais avec des pays dans l'union
j'ai dit évidemment il leur faudrait un
traitement spécifique ou particuliers et
donc pour ceux qui sont internes à
l'union européenne afin des pays
concernés en tout cas cette question
sera tranchée par le conseil européen de
la semaine prochaine
monsieur le ministre je crois que vous
avez répondu à toutes les questions elle
a voulu peut repartir
ces surnoms mais c'était bon qu'est ce
qu'il y avait d'autres non ah oui la
liste la liste olivier la liste parce
que ça c'est quand même l'annnonce du
soir ça ne vous a pas échappé c'est à
dire que quand on a continué ce qu'avait
dit la presse affaires le le
gouvernement a décidé un peu de de
changer le corner qui nous avait proposé
mais une proposition
c'est une proposition c'est nous qui
disposons de ceux des est effectivement
que des personnes qui présentent
certaines comorbidités comme on dit
pardon des maladies qui les rendent
encore plus fragile au virus il n'y
avait pas de raison qu'elle ne soit pas
aussi prioritaire dans la vaccination
alors maintenant quelles sont ces
pathologies là ils vous font donc ça
tombe bien
non effectivement il ya plusieurs
maladies qui peuvent exposer à des
risques de formes graves de coronavirus
vous en connaissez certaines qui ont
beaucoup moins d'impact d'ailleurs que
l'âge quel que soit l'état de santé plus
on est avancée en âge plus on a de
risques de faire des formes graves
c'est ainsi et donc la haute autorité de
santé professeur fisher qui ont défini
une liste qu'on va dire d'ultra
vulnérables qui va être communiqué je
pense qu'elle va être sur le site du
ministère elle l'est sur le site du
ministère me dit on au ministère de la
santé et des solidarités
et c'est important de se référer à cette
liste parce que il faut que la personne
qui présente cette co morbidités
puissent ensuite aller voir son médecin
qui sur la base du diagnostic pourra lui
donner du délivré une ordonnance en vue
d'être vacciné le diabète ne figure pas
dans la liste mais j'ai cité quelques
pathologies ou quelques situations de
vie qui peuvent exposer à des risques de
forme grave je ne ferai pas toute la
liste complète qui aussi des hémopathies
malignes sous traitement avec
chimiothérapique star donc je ne vais
pas ici la décliner dans sa totalité
mais elle et elle est facilement
identifiable et c'est important ne
suffit pas d'avoir une maladie chronique
pour pouvoir accéder à la vaccination la
semaine prochaine il faut que ce soit
encore une fois corroborée par un
médecin sur la base de ces indications
qui sont définies par les autorités
scientifiques
allez un dernier jeu de questions en
avait pas sur la culture
monsieur premier istres bonsoir mesdames
et messieurs les ministres à niveau
d'eau pour europe 1 certains de nos
voisins en europe sont dans des
situations sanitaires assez alarmante et
vous sent pas très alarmiste ce soir
vous avez évoqué la possibilité d'un
confinement si les choses dérapent aime
et on vous sent pas très alarmiste et
puis d'un point de vue économique
vous avez annoncé de nouvelles nouvelles
mesures très attendues ça ressemble à la
suite du quoi qu'il en coûte comme bien
est-ce que à combien puisque vous
chiffrer ces nouvelles aides
comment est ce que vous les financer et
puis avec monsieur le maire on connaît
évidemment vovo vos principes sur la
rigueur budgétaire que vous n'avez pas
des sueurs froides quand vous énoncez
tous ces chiffres
allez une dernière quatre ans bonsoir
loïc besson bfm tv sur les écoles
d'abord on a entendu le président du
conseil scientifique être très inquiet
de l'arrivée de ces variants est appelé
à l' augmentation gilles ans notamment
dans les écoles en quoi les règles
sanitaires vont être durcies vous avez
parlé des tests 1 millions par semaine
mais concrètement quels seront les
moyens à déployer pour ça et puis un mot
sur la culture parce qu'on n'en a pas
parlé dans les questions est ce qu'il ya
un certain type de salle cinéma théâtre
qui pourront ouvrir avant d'autres quid
des musées est ce qu'il y à un critère
quel est votre critère finalement
sanitaire une donnée qui pourrait vous
permettre de décider enfin de les
rouvrir ou est ce qu'on peut dire
clairement il faut attendre d'avoir
vacciné
le gros des français merci bien
je demande peut-être au ministre de
l'économie de se préparer je vais pas
votre première toutes leurs questions
qui effectue importantes d'abord je ne
suis jamais alarmiste d'accord alarmiste
je suis vigilant toujours depuis le
début
on va dire je je ne crois pas avoir la
réputation de mollir lorsqu'il faut
prendre des décisions
d'accord quelle qu'en soit la difficulté
compris politiques
je pense avoir toujours privilégié le
critère sanitaires sur toute autre
considération
vous avez raison de dire que la
situation en europe est difficile dans
certains pays
dramatique dramatique vous en connaissez
des raisons je vais pas vous les voulez
rappelé donc j'essaie à la fois nous
essayons d'analyser avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement et en particulier ministre
chargé de la santé la situation
épidémique en france actuelle est
projeté actuelle est projetée et donc
comme je l'aï indiqué dans mon propos
nous avons des indicateurs
épidémiologique qui à ce jour aurait
rendu sans doute excessif en confinement
faudra m'expliquer je veux pas venir
vous expliquer un jour que je re
consignes tout le pays shabazz de tels
critères vous ne manqueriez pas de me
faire observer que ces critères ne soit
absolument pas réunies si j'avais fait
l'index est donc en réalité comme je les
dis ce soir les mesures de durcissement
que nous avons prises qui sont réelles
qui certes ne vont pas jusqu'au
confinement elle s'explique par le fait
que les chiffres pour être un peu
meilleure que dans les autres pays ne
sont pas non plus exceptionnellement
bornes c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
et puis surtout pour tenir compte de cet
environnement de ceux de ses vues des
virus variant il faut se préparer et ce
sera un moment le dernier élément de
réponse
voilà que nous suivons la situation au
jour le jour je crois que nous avons
d'ailleurs amélioré et nous sur mal à
nous parce que nous le monde entier
les outils de suivi de la crise pour
être en capacité de réagir dès que
possible c'est toujours vous savez
un dosage l'équilibré recherché
extrêmement difficile voilà ça nous
amène à la question où ça nous ramène à
la question sur l'école
c'est à dire que vous voyez bien que je
les dis le critère sanitaire est le
premier des critères mais il se peut
qu'arriver à fermer ou à confiner les
10500 et aussi des conséquences
sanitaires psychologiques et c'est donc
cette série de paramètres que nous
devons utiliser pour expliquer à nos
concitoyens le fondement de décision le
fait qu'elle soit difficile à prendre
oui nous savons depuis un moment mais il
faut qu'elle soit adaptée aux
circonstances
c'est comme ça qu'elles seront le mieux
comprises et je laisse faire le mieux
acceptée d'où l'idée pardon ce qui me
fait passer la balle à mon voisin
bien que ceux qui sont impactés par les
mesures comprend et ne doutait pas qu'il
y aura un impact de l'avancement du
couvre-feu à 18 heures n'en doutez pas
d'ailleurs s'il y avait aucun impact sur
le prendrais pas il bien il faut aussi
qu'ils bénéficient de la solidarité
nationale est gardé par l'état pour
répondre précisément vos questions
d'abord combien ce que coûtent les
mesures que nous venons d'annoncer ses 4
milliards d'euros par mois
l'augmentation du fonds de solidarité
les exonérations de charges la prise en
charge des coûts fixes notamment pour
les louis ces 4 milliards d'euros
mensuels n'inclut pas les coûts liés à
l'activité partielle
c'est uniquement les coûts liés aux
mesures que j'ai annoncée est-ce que
nous avons les moyens financiers de
supporter ces dépenses supplémentaires
la réponse est oui parce que nous avons
été prévoyants nous avons à la fois
dégager des moyens supplémentaires pour
2021 et nous aurons aussi j'aurai
l'occasion de le préciser la semaine
prochaine avec le ministre des comptes
publics
olivier du soft le report de dépenses
qui n'ont pas été effectuées en 2020
prenez l'exemple du confinement
en novembre nous ont perdu 12%
d'activités là nous avions perdu 30 pour
son activité au 1er confinement donc
nous avons des reports de dépenses qui
n'ont pas été effectués par ce que
l'impact du deuxième confinement sur
l'activité économique a été moins fort
que celui du premier alors même que nous
avions prévu un impact aussi fort
troisième question est ce que c'est le
bon choix stratégique je vais vous
répéter ce que nous répétons aux
prémices et le présent la république
depuis le début d'abord c'est le choix
qu'ont fait tous les états européens
et c'est un choix de justice et de
raisons de justice parce qu'aucun ces
restaurateurs de seebach de ses hôtels
de ses salles de sport de ses salles de
spectacles de culture n'a demandé à
fermer ils sont victimes des règles
sanitaires
donc il est juste que nous les
soutenions est ce que c'est le bon choix
économique oui parce que nous protégeons
des compétences et nous protégeons les
entreprises et cela garantit ensuite la
relance économique la plus rapide
possible
si vous voulez relancer l'économie mais
qui a plus d'entreprise et qui a plus de
salariés pour faire tourner les
entreprises que vous n'allez pas aller
très loin
enfin quatrième question est ce que
cette augmentation de la dette publique
liés à ces dépenses supplémentaires
devra être remboursé la réponse est oui
je le redis tous ceux qui prétendent que
l'on ne rembourse pas sa dette tiennent
des propos qui sont irresponsables
il faudra rembourser cette dette il
faudra le faire le moment venu
c'est-à-dire une fois que la crise
sanitaire sera derrière nous le faire
avant ce serait risquer de tuer dans
l'oeuf la reprise et sur la base d'une
stratégie que je proposerai au premier
ministre et au présent la république en
tenant le plus grand compte des
recommandations de la commission que le
prémunit sera mis en place et qui est
présidée par jean arthuis
merci j'invite misé questions
internationales à venir pendant qu'il
arrive permettent d'ajouter deux choses
compte tenu la réponse précise une
économie d'enfants je sais que vous en
êtes convaincu mais si on ne faisait pas
cela combien de drames humains
combien de drames
quel coût économique aussi quels coûts
économiques et payer tous ces gens là
seraient au chômage dans des situations
dramatiques donc ça a un coût dont il ya
enfin ce que c'est c'est un choix qui
nous honore un soin qui nous honore et
deuxième chose que je vais vous dire par
rapport à votre question c'est que je
parlait d' équilibre on va dire que on
peut être certainement pas alarmiste
très vigilant très inquiets on peut dire
aussi en toute lucidité que ce deuxième
confinement finalement il a produit des
résultats sanitaires dont l'ensemble des
commentateurs considèrent qu'ils sont
plutôt satisfaisants au sein de l'union
européenne et par rapport à nos voisins
s'en sent comme bruno le maire l'a
appelée faire s'effondrer complètement
l'économie
elle s'est même - effondré que nous ne
l'aurions prévu du coup elle coûtera
moins aux finances publiques par rapport
à votre question ce deuxième confinement
que nous ne l'avions anticipé est
budgétée et donc ça nous redonne un peu
de marge pour faire face à cela
donc ça veut dire que tout ça a été très
difficile je pense à tous ces
commerçants que la ferme et les acteurs
de la culture on revient et c'est à tout
ça est dramatique mais on avait là aussi
trouver un équilibre entre les
impératifs sanitaires qui sont toujours
en premier et aussi le maintien de
l'activité économique et social l'autre
priorité je le martèle l'école
l'éducation l'école l'éducation est là
aussi en termes relatifs monsieur le
ministre nous tenons le choc mais il
faut être là aussi vigilant voudrait
parfaitement la journée fut bien sûr sur
l'école ce que l'on peut dire d'abord
c'est que au moment du départ en
vacances de noël
on avait un taux que l'on avait calculé
sur les lycées qui était de 0 3% sur la
base justement des campagnes de tests
que nous avons fait en décembre
cette ce taux nous permettait de dire
que l'épidémie était sous contrôle si on
peut dire dans le milieu scolaire
c'est vrai que depuis lors l'élément
nouveau c'est le variant
et les craintes que l'on a dans
l'ensemble de la société commune en
milieu scolaire sur ce que cela pourrait
signifier en termes de contagiosité
depuis c'est à dire depuis le retour des
vacances de noël
nous regardons évidemment comme nous le
faisions avant un jour par jour les
contaminations qui existe dans le milieu
scolaire
ce que nous observons c'est une courbe
qui ressemble exactement la coupe que
nous avions retour des vacances de la
toussaint
cette courbe donc est une courbe qui est
un peu comme une cloche là on est au
sommet de la cloche actuellement c'est à
dire autour de 2000 à 3000 contamination
déclaré par jour je rappelle que ce
chiffre est forcément sous-estimé par
rapport aux données réelles puisque nous
avons deux courbes la courbe des
déclarations tous les jours de
contamination et puis la courbe de santé
publique france qui est ce que les
administrations de la santé peuvent
recueillir grâce aux données
personnelles sur la santé et l'intérêt
c'est d'avoir c'est de voir ces deux
courbes qui suivent tendance parallèle
le fait que ça augmente peu de temps
après les vacances nous indique surtout
que c'est pendant les vacances que des
contaminations ont lieu chez des enfants
ce qui au passage souligner que
lorsqu'on dit que les enfants ne
devraient pas être à l'école ça veut
dire qu'on l'aimé ailleurs et quand dans
cet ailleurs très souvent ils
contaminent davantage rappelons le aussi
évidemment c'est un argument
supplémentaire pour ne pas fermer les
échos l'argument principal étant
évidemment celui dit par le premier
ministre c'est à dire que l'éducation
c'est pas une variable d'ajustement
l'éducation c'est pas quelque chose de
marginal l'éducation c'est fondamental
pour chaque enfant de france et du monde
d'ailleurs donc cette courbe nous là
nous la suivons évidemment de manière
quotidienne et bien entendu si elle
devait monter très haut elles nous
amèneraient à prendre des mesures plus
restrictives encore mais pour l'instant
nous considérons qu on est sur des
chiffres qui sont finalement comparable
à ce que nous avions au début du pendant
la première quinzaine du mois de
novembre
ensuite est-ce que les mesures et c'est
la deuxième partie de vos questions sont
adaptés à cette à cette situation
au fond nous avons des points de
fragilité dans la vie quotidienne de nos
élèves
premier point de fragilité c'est la
cantine évidemment c'est évident et
évidemment la solution de facilité ce
serait fermée les cantines mais là aussi
nous aurions des inconvénients qui
serait probablement supérieurs aux
avantages
rappelons que lorsqu'on était en
confinement
en mars avril et qu'il ya eu le retour
au mois de mai il y avait des pétitions
parfois pour ouvrir les cantines même
sans ouvrir les écoles tant les
inconvénients socio éducatif même est
tout simplement les en termes
d'alimentation quotidienne des enfants
posaient des problèmes du fait de cette
fermeture donc la cantine c'est
important aussi ça ne se sacrifient pas
comme ça et donc nous la meuse et des
mesures que nous prenons ce sont
simplement des mesures d'encadrement
plus rigoureuse de la cantine
parfois cela peut aller dans certains
endroits jusqu'à la fermeture de la
cantine quand on n'arrive pas à remplir
ces conditions strictes c'est un sujet
de dialogue quotidien avec les
collectivités locales
si en responsabilité sur ce coup les
autres mesures que nous prenons sont des
mesures qui sont faites pour toujours
plus limité les brassages
c'est le cas notamment de l'hybridation
en lycée et beaucoup plus rarement en
collège et puis l'autre mesure
évidemment c'est en matière de
l'éducation physique et sportive on sait
là aussi c'est parfaitement démontré que
l'activité de manger d'une part
d'activité souffle et d'autre part et
d'enlever son masque tout simplement
conduisent éventuellement à des
contaminations
c'est évidemment la mort dans l'âme que
nous supprimons cette activité j'ai
utilisé le mot suspendre parce qu'encore
une fois nous avons des protocoles
sanitaires strictes sport par sport
domaine par domaine et j'espère bien
qu'on pourra ré ouvrir parce que là
aussi l'activité physique des enfants
ça n'est pas négligeable je t'ai
conscience aussi à la créativité de
toussaint les activités physiques de
plein air reste possible bien entendu
espérons que la météo permettra qu'elle
soit effective est en tout cas c'est
dans ce sens que nous travaillons merci
beaucoup de jeu vous propose pour
répondre à la dernière question d'âme la
ministre culture non on ne prend plus de
questions à ce dernier le premier
ministre pour répondre et donner de la
visibilité il faut tenir compte du fait
par dont il faut tenir compte du fait
que la situation sanitaire laden
sanitaire a profondément changé avec
l'apparition des variants et de l'heure
pouvoir de contamination changer
accéléré telle que la décrit olivier
ferrand nous travaillons donc dans deux
directions
d'abord nous avons renforcé nos liens
avec le ministère de la santé pour
approfondir et solidifier nos
connaissances sur sur tous ces sujets
nous avons des groupes de travail un
groupe de travail en commun avec olivier
ferrand pour regarder l'impact de la
contamination des contaminations dans
les lieux dans les lieux de culture
nous regardons également dans ce cadre
avec beaucoup d'attention des
expérimentations qui sont menées je
pense à l'expérimentation barcelone par
exemple ou de leipzig et nous avons deux
organisations qui vont mener des
expérimentations
le syndicat des musiques actuelles avec
l'inserm et le prodiss avec l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris pour regarder
que ce qui se passe dans les lieux de
culture
avec cette nouvelle donne sanitaire qui
est la nôtre on voit que les conditions
qui ont été posées dans ses
expérimentations sont des conditions
extrêmement strictes comme par exemple
l'obligation de par un test pcr de
conditionner ainsi l'entrée dans les
salles de spectacle ou également les
questions de ventilation de température
de port d'un masque ffp2 et de
conditions de sécurité extrêmement forte
qui pose un certain nombre de problèmes
de généralisation secteur c'est donc le
deuxième axe qui est le nôtre dans les
lieux de culture c'est de travailler
avec les acteurs de la culture à un
modèle résilient nous avons d'ailleurs
commencé ce travail des avants noël sous
votre égide monsieur le premier ministre
je dois dire que le monde de la culture
est extrêmement facilitateur dans ce
domaine est prêt à accepter des
conditions très très stricte au niveau
des jauges au niveau des distances
au niveau des conditions d'en tisser psy
et effectivement je souhaite aussi se
développer dans la dans le cadre de la
procédure tous antico vide aussi avec
des qr codes qui permettrait s'il y
avait une contamination de retrouver à
proximité les gens qui pourraient être
contaminés donc nous travaillons donc
dans ces deux directions la recherche
scientifique la solidification des
données scientifiques pour garantir la
sécurité des personnes et de nouvelles
conditions de fréquentation des salles
en tout cas ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'effectivement à calendrier glissant
pourraient être faits dans ce domaine
qui pourrait permettre une réouverture
échelonné des lieux de culture en
fonction des données scientifiques
spécifiques à chacun de ces lieux de
culture
merci beaucoup allez bonne soirée à tous